[Music]
what are your superpowers superpowers
dude I don't even know how to pee in
this thing my favorite part of the movie
and the trailer really are when Billy
and Freddy kind of discover Shazam
superpower abilities and they go through
this like superpower checklist so to
speak and you know he's getting it all
on video if you guys had a superpower
checklist what would be at the top of
your list David yes no no LA traffic I
thought a lot about it I have read a lot
of comics over a lot of many years I've
played many video games and seeing all
the movies and I think teleportation
after weighing all of the pros and cons
is definitely the way that you want to
go the one thing that I know life's not
fair yeah you can't have it all get have
it all where would you catch it well
that's the thing like in the same way I
mean I mean to like I've literally sat
down and wait all this out uh flight is
awesome because you can go places you
know like whenever you want to go there
except that you have a lot of things a
lot of variables to consider like wind
speed and do you need to wear like a
face mask cuz there's like bugs and
things in the air and how fast can you
get there teleportation is an
instantaneous travel to wherever you
wanna go so you get to travel a bit but
then also as we know in comic book lower
and whatnot it's like whatever you're
touching goes with you when you teleport
so then you know depending on how good
you are with your digits you could like
touch like ten bags and ten friends and
you're all like in Bermuda yeah and a
half a second and unless you have
super-strength you're not gonna be able
to fly and carry everybody there that's
true
guys just put some thought into it you
thought about this I got teleportation
Trump's flying and it's nice yeah see
trumped mine would be probably getting
guys to text me back I feel like that
I'd be good or like eliminating ghosting
that was my number two guys
eliminating gusting um what I love about
Billy and Friday is that they are such
fans of the superheroes that we kind of
grew up with in London you were saying
you know you read all the comic books he
played all the video games and I just
loved their love of Superman and Batman
and I almost feel like David were
talking about religion earlier I grew up
in a Batman household and it's almost
like a religion like Batman was passed
down to me and so I just was raised
loving Batman yeah so who were your
guys's favorites growing up it was
Superman when I was a kid I sort of
turned into Batman cuz he was kind of
cooler as you got a little older but no
I was definitely Superman like no
Christopher Reeves you know why do you
think Batman's cooler than Superman he's
just you know we're moodier and like
cooler and like a playboy like the whole
the whole Bruce Wayne thing is really
cool and a billionaire and you know yeah
and he's got like he's he's got issues
I mean Superman's got issues too but
Superman is Superman is the the ultimate
boy scout he will always choose good he
will you know and he also has kind of
like that like almost like Spock meets
Boy Scout because he's an alien so he
sees things were much more logically and
less emotionally than humans do I
suppose so but that also kind of makes
you a bit of a square right like a cool
square but said to be square but I mean
you know I mean and by the way there's
obviously different iterations of all
these characters yeah yeah yeah that
one's more complex who was your favorite
I was uh I was actually a big x-men kid
growing up I just loved the idea of
mutants I liked the idea I thought it
was actually the most attainable way
that we could all become superheroes
it's like somehow in our genetic coding
there's gonna be some weird mutation
because that does happen we all have
looked weird you know that you get a
different color I or you know recessive
genes and you know that but ie puberty
puberty
by the way also why I think another
reason why comic or at least the mutants
kind of speak to a lot of like
prepubescent or PMS and like kids is
because it is it goes in and
hand-in-hand with that you like you're
changing your body's changing you don't
know what's going on same thing was
going on with all these mutants like all
of a sudden out of nowhere they
Manifest volumes out of their hands or
can read people's minds and how weird
and crazy that is and trying to
acclimate to that I found that very
relatable so I really liked all those
folks yeah I loved that um a lot of
people have called you know have
compared this movie to Tom Hanks is big
obviously but there is a big reference
in the film so how did that come about
guys well maybe that was the natural
thing to do because it is obviously yeah
very much take it easy we do we do yeah
but they had Penny Marshall I mean you
know you guys exactly Levi's I know well
n David up Sandberg thank you and Jack
Dillon grazer and asher angel and the
whole smattering of incredible people
but there's more than just one reference
to big there Oman you know like give you
yeah there's there's a couple different
moments where we're trying to kind of
throw some love back that way and also
you know when you have an opportunity to
make a movie that has this kind of heart
and humor and irreverence you know it's
fun to have a couple moments are you a
little cheeky and you kind of nod into
that you don't break it you don't break
the story of the fourth wall but you can
lean into that and those can be really
fun little Easter eggs totally and like
so nostalgic too and there's so much
nostalgia in this movie like we were
talking about Billy's family of brothers
or siblings they're basically like this
motley crew and when I was watching it
it reminded me of like the Sandlot
almost yeah so what did you guys look to
to find that inspiration you know I
wanted to feel like kind of like an 80s
movie but without being you know the
typical sort of pastiche of an eighties
movie where it takes place in the 80s
and everything like that but just have
that sort of feel good feel of like The
Goonies you know very ambling yeah yeah
yeah and that sort of went through all
of it even through like you know when we
made the score for it like it's very
sort of you know towards John Williams
type of feel to it so yeah I want to
feel like those movies without
necessarily being
yeah and it makes it so like timeless to
the tone of this movie is just awesome
I'm for Billy specifically I personally
love his story because he's moving from
foster home to foster home and I think
that is a unique story to tell
especially in the superhero realm so
what was important for you guys to
convey to the audience about that type
of family dynamic and environment that
at the core of it it's that you know
family isn't necessarily about blood
it's about you know finding your own
family and that anyone can be your
family which is a yeah and I would also
add I think just the fact that we have a
movie that deals with the foster care
program that by the way is all you know
it's from the source materials so it's
not even this is all very much a part of
the lineage of the character and now
that new 52 and this whole family and I
don't I don't know I'd sell and nobody
still to this day has told me about
another character comic character that
is a foster kid or that really dives
into this and I think that's a very cool
thing that we a not really
responsibility and honor that we have to
kind of represent that fairly on screen
and you know and it's not but it's all
it's cracked up no there's a difficult
things it must be very difficult thing
to be a fourteen-year-old kid who's in
and out of foster programs and giving
that the weight that it deserves while
also not you know getting mired in what
all that could be and I think it's quite
unusual to show such a positive sort of
foster experiences and Martin Cooper do
such a good job of lying like their
heart is so real and insincere that and
they really genuinely like hung out with
and took care of those kids when we were
in Toronto they were doing little field
trips together and everything they
really built that family as beautiful I
love that guy yeah you mentioned Zak new
52 I want to talk about dr. sivana
because I feel like he's somewhat of an
unfamiliar villain and so I kind of
thought you guys did tell me more about
him well he was sort of you know he's
been around for a long time I think he
came out before Lex Luthor even and
you know the comic book world so he's
been a very classic like bad guy
throughout you know the years in this
story is one of the few times where he
actually gets powers because usually
he's more of an evil mastermind and here
he actually uses this master of -
mastermind master mastermind during to
acquire you know similar powers so -
Shazam so he actually can take him on
right exactly your thoughts on dr.
interest his characters well yeah I mean
you know it's the this whole world of
you know oh gee Captain Marvel into
Shazam and he dr. sivana starting way
back there and you know that was like
the Silver Age I don't know what would
you call what was beginning a Silver Age
of comics Golden Age you know there was
a lot of you know World War two evil
Nazi doctor kind of stuff that's all
kind of laid in there and I mean
obviously that's not his character in
this movie but you can feel that kind of
mastermind Dury you know it's it's a
really cool like classic archetype of a
bad guy that fits very well into a world
of a this classic archetype of a good
guy you know because that's so much it's
Billy's imagination or whatever he
projects as being like this is the hero
and this is what you're supposed to be
and that's what you're supposed to do
and and so I think that when you you
know having a movie that really
thematically is aside from family and
finding family even if it's not blood
and where you can find that family and
you know finding your own worth in a lot
of ways that Billy does it's a really
classic tale of good versus evil
yeah so in order to tell a good classic
version of that you need a good classic
version of evil you need that kind of
you know sinister guy and I think that
sivanna as an archetype is great for
that Mark Strong is fantastic
as dr. sivana as an actor in general I
just think is so unreal talented I think
he really brought it to life really well
I think you guys brought this to life I
mean everything we just talked about
like you almost get everything you've
ever wanted out of a superhero movie in
this movie yeah last I'm excited for
everyone to see it last question I have
for you guys is if you got to turn into
any
by just saying the word Shazam who would
it be in way complex feeling I would
maybe would want to turn into like
somebody in a different time zone and
lower timezone yeah the GMT no no no no
like like it's literally a different era
like you know it could be a normal
enough person but just to experience
what life was like in like I don't know
the 1930s or the 1820s or or you know
like all of a sudden I could say a word
and I was like switch with somebody
that's like in the future way in the
future I'm like oh my god this is where
we're going yeah interesting I don't
know what that person is still I have
yet to meet them or maybe oh you have
you